what is your price prediction for
bitcoin by december 31st 2021 what end
of year what is bitcoin hit what's the
highest number yeah it's north of two
hundred thousand dollars mark yusuko
sitting before me with a large pepperoni
pizza i'm laughing at that dude i'm
hitting him with pepperonis and
everybody with pepperonis and all the
pompianos and the pepperonis we're all
laughing at this dude
jason and mark for anyone that doesn't
know uh well i guess we're gonna talk
about it now jason and mark have a bet
uh over two hundred thousand dollars no
this i think it's 250 by the way i think
the bet is too thick
i gotta make sure i feel like i'll have
like a little bit of the referee i think
the bet is 250 but maybe it sounds like
something 250 on here i'm here for it i
think it's 250 and uh they they have bet
uh pepperoni pizza over this and the
reason why they arrived at that was uh
regardless of who wins they both get to
eat pepperoni
we're both winners we're both winners
pop will be there too you guys can all
comment out pizza mark's paying
in that case we're going to get two or
three
all right so you think 200 to 250 000
into beer
yeah man i'm telling you
december 31st 11 45 p.m
i'm gonna have the moon
block on the war paint the shirt will be
off i'll have like a probably a hula
what is that thing called lay hula yeah
i will be on it
truly's in both hands
250 000 bitcoin for all of y'all
truly's in both hands is all time
all right i appreciate you coming on
where where can we send people to get
the let's do the book first where where
can we send people best seller
right
you can go to the grocery store you can
go to your the the you know down to the
bodega it's everywhere son or you can go
to amazon.com and check it out there
it's on audible too
number one best seller
the the book is very good i uh i just
went ahead and uh dropped the link in
the chat for anybody who wants to uh to
get it how many did you have to buy to
get to number one best seller zero man i
heard about these shenanigans i'm a poor
man i'm a working man this book is doing
its own thing 600 reviews
congratulations all right
second thing is ever go follow him on
twitter at going parabolic but before
you leave
i want to say thank you to the top 10
best-selling author in macroeconomics
and international finance mr going
parabolic guy jason williams did a
fantastic job i think if we had to rate
jason's performance today what would we
give them out of uh one to ten ten
ten ah perfect
all right you guys are good we're bros
man let's do that
your profile picture is all time
i'm american i love america
i know you guys do too superhero
hi man
i appreciate you coming on we'll talk
soon
see you guys bye